we finally played Gotham Knight that's
right after a couple of delays uh we
have played a big chunk of the brand new
game from Warner Montreal uh Batman is
dead we know this uh we're taking
control of the bat family obviously
there is some uh similarities and
obviously some big differences with the
Arkham games that we all know and love
so Tam and I are here to talk you
through how it differs uh and what is
there what we got excited about what we
liked and what we didn't about the big
two and a half hours that we've played
of the game so Tam overall
um can you set up how you know what we
played where we played it that kind of
thing yeah so first things first uh
Warner Bros flew us out to the Montreal
studio and we played a chunk of the game
um we played a little bit of the open
World
um we did some training exercises and
then we kind of did Co-op and won kind I
guess the equivalent is a RAID or a
dungeon or something like that a big
Co-op activity of sorts and yeah overall
impressions are
I'm not 100 sure what to think about it
I feel like it's this is a tricky one
because we played quite a limited
selection of it and the hard part of it
is
that in that limited selection I don't
think the game put its best foot forward
but it did enough to not outright for me
to panic about it if you know what I
mean
um I think like the most the thing that
I came away thinking about most uh was
the story and the characters but we only
got like glimpses of that and hints at
that in between the actual gameplay
aspect of it and the gameplay aspect of
it is self-fill felt familiar but a bit
awkward which I guess is kind of the
theme for a lot of this game you know
it's like searching for an identity
um and and it feels a bit uncomfortable
in its own shoes a little bit
um it feels familiar in that it's very
much based on
to a degree the fundamentals are the
classic Arkham free flow combat style
but it it's missing a lot of the things
that made that feel good and click like
the rhythm-based stuff the kind of
instant takedowns that build up over
Combos and instead it's got systems that
are replacing that and
It's tricky because those systems are
clearly well reasoned and thought out
but for me they just didn't feel like
they clicked together or feel good in in
action how did you feel about it I will
say that like
once I stopped trying to play it as
Arkham or as Arkham Asylum set your
night or even Origins I was like oh I
get what this is now this is more of a
all-out action
kind of more brawler a more ability
based cooldowns building momentum
executing those big big moves so you
know there's one sequence where you're
kind of breaking out of um I believe
it's black ape it is black gay prison uh
this is the part where you're playing
but like there was there's one big kind
of brute enemy and you know she's only
being able to be taken down by one very
specific uh move that you are taught and
so once I kind of understood and got to
grips with that it was fine but it was
like
swapping from I started the game playing
as Batgirl right and then you played a
little bit as
um uh red hooded yeah as red hood and
then I went back and I played as
Nightwing but in that time Nightwing had
leveled up and I didn't get a chance you
know that like RPG kind of thing where
you you unlock an ability you get to
grip so that you use it and so I was
unlocking all these abilities in one go
and then I didn't necessarily really
understand how I was meant to be using
them yeah I think the biggest challenge
that this games face gonna face and a
lot of the people who play it are gonna
face is trying to get over the idea that
it's another one of those Arkham games
because I think that's the biggest
Pitfall and the tricky part is it does
feel like that at times I think this is
that game those games but like
re-interpreted through the lens of an
RPG that's got like these almost like
games and service hooks if you know what
I mean like the way that a destiny feels
and the way that those kind of like
almost I know sacrilege to make this
comparison but like the event just game
feels where it's not about elegantly
moving from one character to another or
one enemy to another as Batman or even
you know Batgirl or Nightwing because
you could do that in previous games
um and like dispatching them efficiently
um using your various Gadgets in a kind
of fluid
in and out motion where you know you
Glide from one enemy to the next hit
user you know grappling hook to pull
another one over and like double jump or
flip over someone like doesn't have that
fluidity this is more about pushing the
momentum meter which is the big thing
um as high as it can or like filling up
that bar by doing basic attacks heavy
attacks Dodges and like last minute
Dodges so that you can then power up and
enable yourself to to use these special
abilities which are mapped to various
buttons when you hold R1 we're playing
on a PlayStation 5. and then kind of
managing cooldowns and dispatching
enemies in that fashion so it's more of
a case of it does feel a bit like those
games where it's like meter and power
management more than anything else but
as you said it's a different kind of
feel it's not necessarily a bad feel it
just is very very and there are moments
where it is quite like triumphant
there's like red hoods like weird
um weird like gunshot that just likes
seems to home in on everyone and
instantly destroy themselves I was
ridiculous I was not expecting so like
kind of you know you've got the
full God bad girl Nightwing red hood and
Robin and I was like going into it I was
kind of going oh you know Nightwing and
Batgirl uh when we were talking in the
devs at the studio they were like yeah
each night kind of is is a facet of
Batman right and so
I fully anticipated playing those two
characters like throughout but I was I
was shocked with that about how much I
enjoyed Robin like he's the he's the
most stealth uh face character and also
but like red hood as well I was so so
surprised and I feel like that's gonna
be another a thing that surprises people
is that like there are these four
characters that all do feel markedly
different in terms of their abilities
but it's like how are you gonna decide
which one to play as they've done a lot
of good work in making each character
feel distinct um especially like a range
of like the traversal stuff is one part
of it where everyone moves in a very
different way and that aspect of like
Batman you know embodied in each of
these characters really does stand out
like Barbara does seem to she's she's
like she represents that kind of like uh
the kind of they describe it as the
Justice element they're never gonna be
beat down here and like in combat she's
like quite Hardy and she can't get she
feels like very very Nimble whereas like
red hood is very very like ranged and
can you know crowd control pretty well I
really enjoyed playing as Robin because
he had that like Tech side of Batman
where you could use microbots and he
could like put out
um uh decoys of himself to create aggro
kind of like draws and that kind of
stuff so if it works that's been done
that
um makes the characters feel distinct
even if it doesn't have that fluidity
that you might expect I think the tricky
part of it really came down to one on
learning the rhythm-based mechanic I
definitely felt like there was an
element of unlearning and I don't I
don't necessarily think that's a bad
thing but it's like it just it took me a
minute to not try and fall into you know
old Arkham routines the combat is
something that I'm like I'm not 100 sure
on yet and I can't say I'm excited about
but everything else although I can't say
is going to be great or definitely say
it's going to be good I'm way more
interested in way more excited to learn
more about the little hints of the stuff
that we saw were like um so not only the
way that they were kind of talking
amongst each other the banter was I I
really enjoyed it there's like you know
definitely kind of angsty moments
between the four but also just you know
there are I'm a sucker for emails like
in-game emails and messages and stuff
and so we uh uncovered you get emails
obviously sent to the back computer and
there's a bit where Jason Todd's like I
don't want to be that guy but I bought a
pizza and it's gone so who is it but you
know like those moments of of levity
um I like the way the kind of
Investigation flowed um at the beginning
with with Batgirl because you know you
as the player are in the same boat you
don't exactly know what happened to
Bruce what he was investigating before
he died and so that's kind of at the
start of the game and so the
investigation mechanics are pretty cool
like you look at things in that they're
very detailed internal environments now
and so the way that you're matching
things up I was like matching up uh
trying to unlock something with a keypad
and to see if there's anything in the in
the environment and I thought that was
that was genuinely really cool there
were moments where it just it felt like
classic Arkham like it leads you through
um you know like a combat encounter but
then you can go into essentially a
predator room and flex those muscles and
so it's it's hitting the right notes to
me I'm still jury is out for me on the
combat but like I said the huge caveat
is that we had a very strange
introduction to it yeah and like you
said that the stuff that they're doing
with the characters has me most
intrigued like everyone is is like
figuring out who they are in a world
post Bruce
um they're all kind of trying to figure
out what they mean to to the city and
what they can do for it the city is
looking for a new Savior and perhaps
most interestingly like all these
villains now they need a new a new kind
of
um a a nemesis to it to a degree because
he served like seeing Harley learn that
Batman is dead is like really
fascinating and they all have their all
of these Knights have their own kind of
way of doing things so that happens a
lot where clashes were early on you know
Jason Red Hood was just like I'm not
sitting around waiting for you guys to
new nerds to like decrypt hard drives
and stuff like that I'm going out now
but like then you know um Nightwing
stepsons and it's like listen these
don't let's not make the mistakes that
got Bruce killed and and they're trying
to figure out what his final case was
and how we ended up in this situation
and the ultimate goal is you're working
your way to Knight them which based on
the discussion is like we had with a
developer is like one of these
characters will
come out and emerge and take the throne
and be like I am the leader now I am the
new protector of the sea and it's going
to be interesting to see how the others
kind of Vie for that or even if they
like oh like yeah maybe maybe you know
dick is is the right person for this but
um there's definitely a bunch of
so a lot of and the other thing is they
also hang out as not their vigilante
um uh identities they're just like in
the Belfry hanging out occasionally
we'll like chat and there's like some
good incidental dialogue Alfred is there
to try and keep them together and help
them figure disputes out and the
character stuff and the written stuff is
perhaps what I'm most excited about and
it does kind of make sense because I
don't know I thought the most
interesting part of Arkham Origins was
the story stuff and the investigation
stuff and they kind of leaned on the the
you know the well-worn Territory full of
combat and a lot of the gameplay stuff
but I found that story to be really
engaging
um and so it makes it shouldn't be a
surprise that that's what I'm looking
forward to in this game the most but it
is and pretty much everything else feels
like it's going to be good perhaps not
like exemplary or like Reinventing the
wheel I like the way the the game looks
especially on a ground level uh perhaps
like this rooftop level is maybe not as
exciting to look at but you get into the
ground and like the neon Noir as they
describe it is really really cool to
look at and they have a Vibe and they're
definitely going for it um so yeah I'm
I'm like tentatively excited for it um
but I I've come to terms with the fact
that perhaps this won't be like a
mind-blowing kind of Batman experience
that I want I found myself in a world
that I know that I love with characters
that I love that are getting way more
screen time and I'm I'm like that
mystery I it's already got me interested
I hope it keeps on that trajectory like
that it's gonna be enough to pull me in
and keep me uh invested in the whole
thing I want to get to the bottom of it
and I'm
like I can't wait to see what villains
that they are they're being like up
which is not usually the case I remember
Arkham Knight they basically spilled
everything to do with that game in the
Preamble but I think they are keeping
cards close to the chest in terms of
which villains we're going to be
encountering we obviously know about
Harley we know about penguin
and I'm you know the Rogues Gallery is
has got some incredible folks to pull
from and so I'm really intrigued to see
because I think one of the things very
quickly because we've been talking for a
while but like the the way that Holly
reacts to the night at the end of their
fight is like you mentioned the Knights
of figuring out what happens when
Batman's gone but also so are the
villains and they they kind of have this
you know they all had this pre-existing
relationship with Bruce and now they
have to figure out what their
relationship is to Nightwing and red
hood and so I mean I can't wait for that
I do want to like I did appreciate that
it seems like at least based on what
we've seen so far they're not kind of
phoning it in with these characters like
the ver we won't say what this version
of Harley is but she's one that I've not
seen in games for a while she's got a
history that you can probably figure out
if you if you know the modern version of
Harley what she's been up to but like
there's moments where like she's she's
kind of helping them in a way because
she's like she's teaching them how to be
a better Batman or like be more like
Batman it's very strange this Dynamic
like I wouldn't when like we had a
truncated version of the Harley Mission
but they were like nuances to the way
that their character was written and
like was acted that were quite exciting
and if they if that if I extrapolate
that out onto the other villains that
might be in the game I'm hoping that
they take that same approach where it's
like not the same version of freeze that
we're used to not the same version of
whoever else may be in the game but they
have like really
re-contextualizing thought about it in
the in the world that now exist where
Batman and Bruce Wayne don't
know it's coming out October 21st we'll
obviously have a bunch more stuff here
on Gamespot if you're around right now
we've got some gameplay from our trip uh
if you want to go take a look at that uh
you find Tam and I on Twitter I'm at
least James games
I'm atomore H and follow Gamespot for
more on Gotham Knights